I've talked before about how there's
been a worldwide move away from the
United States dollar in the world of
currencies and in November of last year
we did a big story about this where I
explained that the dollar sort of has
this privileged position which is good
for people in the United States it's
used as a trading currency and a lot of
the world two-thirds of global reserves
are in dollars two-thirds of all
physical dollar bills are outside of the
US so the point of the story I did back
in November is that there's significant
global reliance on the dollar and that
this is good for the United States in a
few ways it helps to keep interest rates
low
it makes selling bonds easy because so
many countries around the world already
have dollars it makes our exports worth
more because there is more demand for
our currency it gives us a geopolitical
negotiating clout clout it's positive
for us in a bunch of different ways but
partially because of Donald Trump's
tariffs world countries have started to
move away from the dollar which is not
good for the United States in a number
of ways not only has the story been
growing it's actually now sort of tying
into Russia's manipulations and the
positioning of China geopolitically
because remember that the context here
is Russia's geopolitics for decades have
been to sow discord in the United States
carryout I guess we'd call them
initiatives to make people question the
stability of our democratic systems we
saw them do that with the 2016 election
create tension create conflict and
they've been doing it really really well
and what Russia is now doing
economically is shifting their financial
reserves away from the United States
dollar and towards the Chinese yuan
which will be yet another way in which
they are going to help destabilize the
United States as well as euros and some
Japanese yen what Russia did back in
April we just learned about it now or
maybe it was later in 2018 is they sold
about a hundred billion dollars in u.s.
holdings from its reserves and they
shifted that hundred billion into
Chinese yuan euros and yen this is not
just an economic
decision and economically it may not
even be that great for them in the short
run but it is part of their geopolitical
tactics and strategy and the antics that
they've become known for part of this is
well if they sell some of their US
dollars they'll be less exposed to US
sanctions against them if you don't have
as many US dollars you're less impacted
by those American sanctions but the
political aspect of this goes beyond
that because Putin said just a couple of
months ago quote we aren't ditching the
dollar the dollar is ditching us which
of course is interesting in the sense
that he is saying well there are
elements of the dollar that are not good
for us to hold it as a reserve currency
but it's all part of the geopolitical
play that Putin is doing and I have to
tell him it's sort of genius right I
mean in a way this is a multi-pronged
attack in every way
Putin has Trump and the US over a barrel
and I want to be really clear because I
know people will write in and say David
you know you're you're understating the
fact that this move could be bad for
Russia economically that's right if you
evaluate this decision that Russia's
making to get away from the dollar only
short-term economics it could actually
be bad for Russia the yields on some of
the currencies Russia's shifting to are
lower than yields on the US dollar in
the short term this might actually hurt
Russia economically to some degree but
in geopolitics that really doesn't
matter the dollars not doom the dollar
is going to be fine whether or not
Russia shifts reserves in or out
it's the clout and the positioning of
the United States that's increasingly in
question on the world stage one way in
which the dollar and our bonds could be
headed to a downgrade is if the shutdown
continues I read a couple of pieces
suggesting that our credit rating could
be downgraded if the shutdown goes on
much longer
Putin is actually the guy who is playing
the 4d chess in a way that Trump can't
conceive of I wish it weren't the truth
it doesn't make me happy
to come to you and say look at the
clever stuff Putin is doing to have the
United States and Trump over a barrel
but he's doing it and he's actually
doing it pretty well